hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
crispr cass
assisted genetics and intestinal
organoids
presented by dr ban kyung ku the group
leader
at the institute of molecular
biotechnology imba
i am michelle ashton of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by gen script
for more information on our sponsor
please visit www.jenscript.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our speaker dr
ban kyung ku
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen bk you may now
begin your presentation
right thank you everybody for joining
the
seminar today today i'm going to talk
about
uh organic as a model system and
we'll basically introduce some genetic
engineering tools
so that you can utilize organic as a
model system in your laboratory
first of all i'd like you to
pay attention to the picture that you
see now in the first slide
so these are a mouse intestinal organoid
with many
body instructor so there are many body
structure around
uh in the middle where we see this dark
area we have
differentiated cells and in this body
structure we have
proliferating progenitors as well as
stem cells
to understand this organic system uh
nicely well i think it is very important
to understand
the gut biology so i will start
introducing
how the stem cell in the gut is working
and then i will move on to the next
okay so in the gut we have
two distinctive structure one is called
astillus where we have
many absorptive cells and cells that are
secreting nutrients and so on
and these are mostly important for
digestion function
whereas these cells that are located in
the village
they are completely lost within a week
of time
meaning that the entire tissue needs to
be regenerated
in a weekly basis and to have such a
regenerative capacity
we do need to have adult stem cells that
can replace this
tissue and over the many uh
decades people were wondering where the
stem cells are
so when i was a phd student uh no one
actually knew
the exact location of stem cells but now
by sometime in 2007 and 8 we got to know
the real
identity of the stem cell so basically
stem cells are located in this crypt
structure at the very base of the
structure
and what we know now is that this adult
stem cell
can give rise to stem cell cells which
means
self-renewal and they can also
differentiate into
four different cell types such as
associative anterocytes
goblet cells enter endocrine cells and
panic cells
so conceptually we already had a an idea
of adult stem cells
about you know 15 years ago but
at the time nobody knew about the exact
identity as i mentioned
the very important
finding at the time that was made by
nick barker
a former colleague of mine in the
netherlands
he generated ldl5
gp knocking mouse with which he was able
to
visualize this ldl5 positive stem cells
in the mouse small testing so this ldl5
is a genetic marker
which labels the stem cell population
so nick not only labeled them but also
introduced a cree or recombinase
in the downstream of ldl5 so i
don't have a slide for the details
but i can tell you how the experiment
was working so conceptual is very easy
to understand
so what nick has done is he had a
genetic labeling system
that only worked in the stem cell
expressing ldl5 so he marked
his ldl5 positive cells to change the
color
in blue and this changes of color
is triggered by genetic change so all
the progeny that comes out from the stem
cell
will take over the same features so that
they show the blue color in the dota
cell
so on day five you see this nice ribbon
formation
coming out from the bottom of the crit
and this continues to
the village if you look at the image on
day 16
and this again continues up to six
months of time
and nick actually checked the fame in
her mouth where
he was following this stem activity
over one year of time which is almost
equivalent to the mouth life stand
so by doing so he found that the very
first
ldl5 positive cells that are residing in
the base of the crypt
is indeed a stem cell that can replenish
the tissue for
such a long time and at the same time
he also labeled other cell types in this
blurry one
to identify that the stem cell stables
are initially labeled in the bottom of
the crypt
could generate globulin cells and you
can see this with a
white arrow in between these two global
cells we have
enterocytes there are also panel cells
you can also see enteroendocrine cells
so all this data
meaning means that the firstly labeled
ldfi positive stem cell is the real stem
cell population
of the intestine so this was published
in 2007
which is like 13 years ago from now
but after that since we have identified
the stem cells
in the gut we were wondering how to
grow them in vitro so the next question
uh that our lab had at the time was
carried over
out by toshiro sato so toshi had a
brilliant idea
that he wanted to grow the stem cells
out of the gut in a plastic dish
to be able to show that the stem cells
that are functioning in the gut is
indeed hazardous cancer function
in vitro as well but individual
condition is different from individual
conditions so he failed
multiple times in setting up the culture
condition
after many trials he
basically found a very magical
combination which is a growth factor
combination
such as combined by egf
or nitrogen login to block bmp signal
and are responding for activating wind
signaling and and
in addition to these three growth
factors he also found
another very important ingredient which
is the actress extracellular matrix
so after adding this single stem cell
isolated from the god that it presses
this
nice ldl5 gp he embedded them
firstly in matrigel extracellular matrix
and gave the media containing egf login
and arts funding and after that he found
that the single stem cell
could grow out into the statistic
structure
and within about two weeks of time he
again found them to growing into this
body structure and after they formed
this body structure he performed
histology
and found that the body is looking like
a
crypt structure which is very similar to
the individual counterpart that you see
on the left side
in addition to rosato found that
this complicated body instructor can be
split into pieces did it again in the
matrix gel
and if you give a media again and they
could grow
again and again with the weekly uh
splitting activity
so that he was able to culture them for
longer than a year of time
without major genetic changes and he
also found them to be
able to make a self-organizing structure
so this was the first organized culture
that was derived from other stem cells
so when he examined the structure more
carefully
he found that although it was uh
initiated from
single ldl5 plastic stem cell you could
find that
ldl5 positive cells are located in every
body structure of the crimp of the
organoid
he also found that there are many
idio-positive
cells in the body structures
meaning that these are proliferating
progenitors
and not only this stem cell and
progenitors he also found
villian positive enterocytes region two
positive goblet cells
lysozyme prostate plant cells and
chromogram dna properties anti-endocrine
cells meaning that
the four cell types that you can
normally find from the
intestinal epithelium so these started
from single stem cell
and found them to be from multiple stem
cells as well as progenitor and four
different cell types
so this simple experiment uh indeed
showed the stems activity
of ldl5 positive cells again in vitro
but the interesting point is that by
doing so
uh toshiro was able to establish the
organic culture for the first time
so this is the schematic drawing to show
how organ is looking when it becomes
fully mature we have this voting
structure which we call crypto domain
and in between this boarding structure
we have a village domain
where we have many uh differentiated
cell types so now we are going to
look at a movie where i can show you how
organ is growing in real time
okay so i hope that everybody has seen
the video
so in the video uh you were seeing a
cystic structure
maturing into the body structure and
that
takes about a week of time and
if you uh split them by giving a shear
force with a
pipette then each spotting structure
can be seeded back to the material and
if you give a media
then they can form assist structure
again and the single cyst
will become a budding structure again
again within a week of time
so this means that in a week a single
bot
will become a body structure containing
five to six spots around
so if you repeat it for if repeat this
for about a year of time this means that
you can achieve
five to fifty seconds of
expansion which means that
now the adult stem cell-based organic
system
can also be utilized as a very nice
source for adult cell in vitro
and this technology has now been applied
to
multiple organs in the mouse body as
well as in the human body
so this is an example of human and now
we can grow
many endodontin-derived tissue from the
human
human body as an organ rate
so this now gives you an opportunity to
utilize
a human organoid or mouse organism for
your own
biological studies and today i'm going
to
emphasize that not only the culture
system
but also the genetic engineering tools
are completely ready for you to
utilize so here i'm comparing
some of the model systems that are uh
very
popular in our field so you know that
there are
warm and fly which is invertebrate model
systems
many of you might have been working with
the mouse and zebra fish
i myself have been working extensively
with the mouse
as well as the cancer cell line if i
compare
mouse and cell lines then the very
obvious
point is that in the mouse since we can
observe
phenotype from by looking at the mutant
physiology
and histology we can
sometimes directly show the
vivo function of the gene but to be able
to do so in the third line
it's not so easy as it is in the mouse
whereas even after crystal revolution i
think
genetic manipulation is too difficult in
mouse
and mouse is not a system where you can
do
screening of chemical compounds and so
on
whereas cell line gives an opportunity
for us to
to do a very easy gene of expression and
knock down
and the screening is also mainly
performed with the cell line system
so one thing that i want to emphasize is
that mouse in the cell line has a very
clear
pros and cons and the organic system is
probably
a new system which combines the positive
side
of the both so you can observe the liver
phenotype
and you can at the same time perform
genetic manipulation
as well as the chemical screening and
many other things
so i made another summary so here you
have an organoid
and it's really up to your imagination
uh this is a vivo system where you can
observe individual phenotype
it's a ever expanding system you can
even try to
kind of preserve uh them as a cell line
uh as if they are like a cell lines
after you
finish your holiday you can come back to
the lab you can throw them and
restart your experiments so this
gives you a lot of freedom it's very
tiny culture so that ligand and
individual treatment is very easy and
you just need to use a very small amount
and you can observe the phenotypical
changes
they are very close from us so you can
either use mouse organize or you can
even try to use human organs to study
human biology
however when i started working with
organized
about 10 years ago so that's like 2009
or 2010
we didn't have a any genetic tools
with which we can properly use
organelles for biological studies
so during the last 10 years my main
focus was
how we can do the genetic control in the
organ system
so i made a very important two slide uh
which might be you know the most
important two slides
that you want to see today so these are
the
one of the two so i would say this is
organoid kinetic ones so these are the
work that i
did during my postdoctoral time in the
hans clevers lab
uh here i listed three main technologies
the first one is about the util
using by using the retro or lentivirus
one can introduce genome expression or
gene knockdown in organized system so
the method was described in this nature
method paper in 2011
after that we wanted to generate it
a bacteria artificial chromosome
transgenic organoid
which might be important for live
imaging
and other applications this was
published in clause
1 in 2013 one very important aspect of
this
publication is that we figured out how
to introduce
very large dna segments uh into an
organism
because bacteria artificial chromosome
often
had around 100 to 150 kb of length
so figuring out how to perform
lip protection and other types of
electroporation in organic
was very important to achieve the next
project so the next project was how we
can utilize
a crisp cut system in the organoid uh
so that we can achieve gene knockout or
even
gene knockings in organic system and
this was established
on the same year when we had a crisper
class introduced in 2013.
and after that we further optimized
the method so
toshi rosato introduced a very nice
electrolyte called
napa 21 in nature protocols in 2015.
this is very nice method so not only my
lab but also many other labs are
utilizing
the same system with a very similar
protocol so i really recommend you to
think about using it if you like to work
with organoid
next when i was in cambridge i started
working with the piggyback system
because this is a a transposon based
system but it works pretty much like a
retro lentivirus so that
anything that is in between the two itr
can nicely be copied into the genome
upon a transfection
so and another thing is retro or
antivirus they have a
problem with the capacity so that up to
seven to eight kb
of dna segment is the maximum size that
you can transfer with the retrovirus
whereas in piggyback we do not have a
such a limitation
so many of the labs who got to know this
is now utilizing this picnic system so
this is also another very important
technology that i really recommend
for you to use next we also figured out
how to
generate conditional knockout using on
organoid
and this was introduced by mylab in 2017
in nature method
so today i'm going to show you a few
examples
firstly this is the example of the first
gp transgender organelles
shining nicely in green initially it was
not
uh i thought to be very easy uh to
achieve
but uh that was not really uh the case
because
uh virus enters uh via the luminance
side
of the organoid so we had to uh grow the
organoid in a cystic structure first
and then after digesting them to expose
the luminous side
toward to the virus and then we could
really
achieve the virus infection and after
that we could grow
them with a viral infection so
this uh whole protocol uh has taken me
about
a year time to achieve the true
optimization
but now this is you know fully uh
described
with also with the protocol paper so if
you
search for my name in pubmed then i
i think that you can easily find those
protocols to utilize this system
uh next one is an example of a pivot
back
node this is a bacterial artificial
chromosome transgenic organoid
where the red pineal cells are shining
in
in red so the movie will be showing how
the
red planet cells is growing together
with organoid
okay i hope that you have seen the
panel cells being formed already in the
system structure
and later ended up in the tip of the
body structure when
because they are secret wins and they
have the organizer function for
the body information
in this slide i wanted to show you that
crispr cast technology can be
utilized to generate mutants organoids
so these are the first crystal mutants
that
i made so on the left we have a mouse
organoid
with the body structure but after having
uh have lost
the apt they now have this cystic
structure
and the same happens with the human ones
so normally they grow with the body
but after losing apc we grow with this
uh nice
specific structure when when we examined
the uh targeted sequence uh we were able
to
show this in the formation uh suggesting
that
uh crispercast works pretty well with
oregano culture
if you know how to properly transfect
them with the crystal toes
so today for the main part
i prepared two stories
the first one is already an old one but
i think it's a very nice one for you to
know
so this is about the first example of a
crisper gene correction
that we tried in the adult human
organoids and the second one is how we
can visualize crystal
system to perform uh gene grna screening
in organoids
so firstly about gene correction
statistic fibrosis is a very common
genetic disease
especially in caucasian population and
especially in the netherlands
there are many patients suffering from
cystic fibrosis
and uh when we were uh when we got to
know the crispr cast technology in 2013
we saw that maybe we can make a
proof-of-concept
experiment by com by applying the
crystal cast technology to organoid
technology
so that we can uh generate uh precise
gene correction of a 55 assist positive
gene
to cure the patient's organ rate
so the very first thing we do was uh
find
establishing a
organized from 55 of these patients
so as you see on the left normal human
control organoids
if you treat them with forced choline
then this triggers cyclic amp
activation in the cell which triggers
water inflows to the lumen
so that they will blow up
like a balloon whereas in the
cf patient organoid since the channel
activity of cftr
is gone so that even after folks calling
treatment
they cannot show any balloon-like
phenotype
so the main task that i had at the time
was
figuring out where in the cftr we have a
mutation
and designing a grna and the targeting
vector
with which we can cure the genetic car
to have the correct sequence so
uh so we we found that the
mutant organoid had a famous mutation
which is
and in generally solution we designed
two guide rna
one attacks the gluten site another one
attacks the
uh the site of pure mycin nutrition type
the reason to use two grna separately
was to just to achieve a higher
efficiency of
success rate and targeting vector
has the ctt correction as well as the
silent mutation
meaning that this changes the nucleotide
sequence
but it doesn't change the amino acid
sequence so the protein will have
no problem but this functions as a
fingerprint
that i can embed it in the targeted
vector so by looking at the that
limitation
one can understand that we have really
done the
gene correction so so what we have done
is
after figuring out this uh mutation part
of the
patient organelles we designed this
targeting vector and the grna
and transfected them all together with
cas9 in the organ
with the hope that we can get some
recombinants
and that works very well so here
you see that uh the missing ctt
is back to normal so you see the cpt is
nicely
uh back in the yellow mark in the
corrected organoid
whereas in the wild time and the current
mutant
the blue part shows a nucleotide
sequence ca
is now changed into cc so this is the
fingerprint that we inserted it in which
functions as a
silent mutation so if you see that i
i think you can believe that we indeed
did a gene correction
and after that we found that uh
blueton's organoid
is now nicely responding to the closed
calling treatment so that we
were able to observe the balloon-like
phenotype
so with that we had a nice paper out
and i'm going to show you a movie that
summarized
the work
okay i hope you enjoyed the movie
and this work has a very good
implication
so a lot of people would know that
ips technology will essentially help
human to have a
autologous cell therapy at some point
but i can also tell you that the oscillo
autoload
cell therapy can also be performed with
organized
in the near future if i compare the two
technologies
i would say that organic forms are
short-cut because
in case of ips technology you have to
reprogram your somatic cells firstly to
ipsl
uh this is an error prone step so you
have to really find out
the correctly reprogrammed ips cells and
after that you have to
undergo this cell should undergo
gene correction and and then the
corrected ips cells should be used for
full differentiated
differentiation into the target cell
types which can then be
transplanted back to the human so this
undergoes
overall three major steps that are
technically very challenging
whereas in case of organoid
as soon as you isolate the organized
form of patients
you just need to do the gene correction
and the uh
the resulted uh corrected organized can
then be used uh
cell therapy directly to human so in
this case there is
just one step to overcome
the reason that organoid has not been
used in cell therapy
is because of the uh extracellular
matrix that we are using we currently
use
material for most of the culture and
this is a
material which is not fully defined so
it doesn't
comply with a good
manufacture protocol that we have to
achieve
for human therapy so if somebody
figure out figure out how to generate a
synthetic
material for the organic culture i think
this can be
achieved in the near future okay
so i will then move on to the second
topic
so this is the work that is currently
being done in my lab
and it is about how to utilize the
crispr cuts
crisper-cut grna screening in organic
culture
and this is a an interesting problem
because
if you think if you look at some of the
grna screening methods that are
published out there
you see that most of them are about
genomic screening with
many many genes to be involved whereas
in organoids this is a miniature culture
so that
we have a some capacity problem so that
the maximum culture we can achieve with
organized is probably
up to like 100 as well so
the idea was how to compromise the uh
grna library as small as possible
that can be carried over by organ
with a maximum size of culture so we
were
adjusting the two in a way that we can
really find
the well-matched size of the two
and we came up with an idea that uh just
about
uh four to five thousand grna is the one
that we can really handle with a large
organic culture
and to also achieve a higher
discovery rate we designed our grna
in a way that we can put two drnas
at the same time and this allows us to
knock our genes in a
uh interesting way so
as you know that when um
vertebrate evolved from invertebrate
there has been
full genome duplication two times so
this means that
in fly one dn1 function is true
almost however in the most of the
vertebrae system
there are multiple genes at least four
dns or three things
that are sharing some of the gene
functions
so these are called as a prologue and
this parallel problem is a very
heavy problem in the mass genetics as
well as in the zebrafish
and also in human so this means that if
you knock out even if you knock out one
gene
there might be another gene that can
compensate the loss
so this makes our genetic study very
difficult
and to circumvent this problem we design
we use this dual guide system
in a way that a single gene can be
attacked by 2g rna
then the efficiency will be higher for
the duodens
each of the drna can attack both genes
in case of trio we assume that one of
the three beams
might be a pseudogene so that by not
taking either a b
or bc or ca you can achieve a very nice
gene knockout of the of the trilogy
and we also achieved tried a similar
approach
for code rules in this case we have to
cover
six different combinations so
we were thinking about targeting
ring domain containing e3 ubiquinone
ligase
with our grna system so which ended up
for 300 tangent with a 3 3
3 840 grna
so this is the pipeline of the
screening system firstly
we have to isolate organized from a
mutant mouse containing
three and case nine so with the
pre-activation we can activate
cat9 then you see this nice green uh
fluorescence
so all these organelles are expressing
cas9 very nicely
we firstly expand them and then we
introduce all this grna library
encoding almost 4000 grnas
in a dual guide system that are taking
300 resins to
compensate the redundancy problems and
after that we left for puro to enrich
the
uh library containing organoid
and then we perform a growth vector
withdrawal
such as the wind is very important for
the growth
so you can take out wind to see which of
the grnas can survive
we also tried inhibition of egf system
easiest signaling to know which of the
ring domain proteins
are involved in the egf pathway so what
is very nice is that
once you perform this massive screening
the resulting survivor clones can can be
just collected all together
and you can do uh the next generation
sequencing
to see which grnas are surviving after
afterwards so i'm going to show you
the results of wind withdrawal first so
here we had a case nine expression
organoid and this is the organic
after a pure selection and after we
remove iceball from the condition
which makes the uh winch stimulation
very
inefficient uh most of the organelles
were dying but there were some surviving
ones
and when we performed the next
generation sequencing of grna
we found that most of the heaps
are the ones that we actually implanted
as opposite controls
which are such as actins apc
that are working in the destruction
complex of the wind pathway
in addition we also have a a pair
called rna4 t3 and zetanola3 these are
the e3 uvt ligase
that functions on the wings pathway as a
negative regulator
so upon the loss of the two uh we also
know that
this endows resistance to ice bonding
withdrawal
interests me in orange you can see that
there is a
another noble pair which is rnf215 and
rn-43
so this is the noble discovery we had
from the hypervideos experiment
so we went on a validation experiment
and here i can show you that uh those
three
the two parts to control xd1 and two
rnf4 t3 and dead and r3
they both show nice resistance upon ico
withdrawal
but the noble recovery which is rna-43
and rna-215
also shows very nice uh organic growth
without ice pointing and this is
solely due to the genetic redundancy
because
if you separate the guide rna
to knock out just x in one or x in two
there is no survival surviving organoids
without export
same goes with rna4 g3 and zr3
and even the rna4 t3 and rna 15 pair
is the case so if you simply knock out
rns 215 alone
there is no survivor at all
so with this i uh i'm sure that i have
shown
how the rna screening is working and
also the importance of thinking about
you know knocking out uh the parallels
at the same time
using the driller guide rna system
so next i'm going to tell you about uh
easiest pathway screening so in this
case we utilize
a very famous uh target therapy
uh reagent jefferson it which inhibits
the tyrosine kinase activity of egfr
uh with the giaffentine if you treat it
in the
normal organelles within three passages
there is no
organic surviving whereas after we
introduce the e3 ligase
ring domain library into the organoid
we were able to see many surviving
organelles in pathetic iii
meaning that there is clearly some
surviving organisms with the
drna so we then checked the next
generation sequencing
and these are the three top candidates
and if i move on we also tested
validate the system so here
we found one very strong hit
which is ps1 and three so if you knock
out
the two at the same time then we found
that the organic becomes
very resistant to the deputy treatment
so currently our lab is working on the
details of the mechanism to understand
how and why uh ps1 3 knockout
can endow uh the resistance t against to
the japanese treatment
okay so this is the end of my
presentation
uh before finishing the talk i'd like to
have
uh i'd like to emphasize the uh
the health that i was getting from jam
script especially
uh whenever i want to generate a
targeting vector
or a single strand audience uh
i i've been using javascript service and
that's why i got to know the company
very
closely and uh and then obtained the
opportunity to
present my work to you today that's why
i wanted to show you
uh in which way i'm cooperating with
james script
uh next uh libra is my home uh
institute and this is a european
institute located in vienna
austria and i think it's a a very nice
home for organized researchers so the
institute is currently
directed by a professor jurgen kloplich
who
has established brain organized for the
first time
i am a junior pi working on other
stem cell organoids and i also have
three other colleagues
uh working on uh blastos blastoid
cardia organoids and blood vessel
organoids
so i think that if someone
if there is a young researchers who are
interested in
organoid biology i would like to suggest
to think about
joining our institute with that
i'd like to thank my people in the lab
especially jihoon kim
who is carrying currently the crispr
grna project and also the collaborators
hyungbong kim for providing the nice
dual guide rna systems
uh and has drivers for mentoring
during my post of time and also
collaboration
afterwards thank you for your attention
so if you have any question i'm happy to
take your question and answer those
thank you bk for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for okay let's go ahead and
get started
okay bk your first question is when will
the organoids be used
in the clinic to treat patients
yeah so it's a very uh good question
so for cell therapy i think uh i
mentioned during my presentation that
one big huddle for now is
finding out a synthetic or some other
materials that is qualifying for a good
manufacturing
procedure to you know utilize organized
for human trial
so once we know how to grow organic in a
matrix that are fully
defined then we will be able to moving
forward secondly
orgonet can also be used as a assay
system
for instance cancel organize is
currently being
considered as a nice sailboat
to predict the patient response upon
various chemo reagents or
target therapy reagents so those are
going to be realized in the near future
so that at some point we may take
overnight
from our cancer firstly to see which of
the drugs are the best
for my cancer to be treated and in this
way
i think oregon can also help human
health many patients in the clinic
great thank you okay moving on this says
hi thank you for sharing your beautiful
work i have a couple of questions
so the first question says what kind of
matrix
did you use to embed the organoids
yeah so the matrix that we are usually
using
is called material
but there are several comparable
matrix materials that you can use such
as bme
or cartex so these are also working
pretty well
there are currently a number of uh
papers out there
which shows a similar activity with a
different substance
but these are still preliminary i have
to say
it has to be extensively tested by many
labs to be
used instead of the material based
system
okay now the second part of this
question says when you split the
organoids
do you digest them to single cells and
if so
what kind of technique and reagents do
you use
okay so i think it might have not been
so clear during my
talk so we we do
uh cryptinization uh only when we do a
viral infection or dna electroporation
for normal splitting uh we normally just
give
a shear force with a p200
so yellow tip is just enough to give a
shear force
and after pipetting for instance
60 times or 100 times you can make
your organelles into a small pieces and
these small pieces can directly
embed it back to a material and you know
then you can lay on media to grow them
again
so normally we do not use any uh
any tracing like substance for
our splitting thank you
now what are the recovery chances of
fibrosis
through crispr
sorry i didn't understand the question
okay let me repeat the question it says
what are the recovery
chances of fibrosis through crispr
um yes
perhaps maybe that user can um type in a
question maybe elaborate
a little bit and then to the next and
come back to it
yes please because um i hear it well but
i couldn't understand what
the question is really right
it looks like they're wanting to know
what are the chances of recovery
recovery right so
it depends on the genes that you are uh
targeting
uh and also the experiments that you do
so
uh i see i i have to answer this in two
ways so one is
when you just want to make a one mutant
with the one grna
i think the recovery rate is pretty high
depending on the genes
i think the most important part is
your selection strategy so either your
targeting vector has a
drug selection marker or you know how to
select a mutant out
secondly in the crispr screening that we
i just showed
when we do the screening with the
certain
inhibitors to kill the cells we do not
know
what are going to survive
so in that case we have to perform the
experiment first
to know the recovery rate
perfect thank you okay your next
question
says what percentage of the cells were
repaired
in the organoid with editing
uh so in this case the editing just need
to be
happening in one single cell because
uh so for instance when we do crystal
editing
in vivo uh the editing efficiency should
be very high
because every cells that we transfect
with the individual editing tools
we want to get a proper correction
whereas if you do that in the xpevo
then you just want to find out the
correct clone
after the editing trials
so in that case i think the uh
efficiency is not really a problem
but once we have a few cells that are
correctly targeted as a
stem cells we can grow them out with the
organic media
and afterwards we can test individual
clones to see whether they have
regained the function we also can then
test whether they have
any off-target effect in the genome and
after having performed extensive
qc i think we can then utilize those
organelles for
death therapy
thank you all right now when comparing
retrovirus and lentivirus for
transduction
and aneroids which one is better in your
opinion
um well many people would prefer to work
with lentivirus because they are more
familiar to it
and the reason that lentil is more
preferred in general is that
it can also infect non-dividing cells
however in case of the organoids the
stem cells that are
need to be infected they are constantly
proliferating
so no matter which one you are using you
can
easily achieve infection
and the stem cell will proliferate out
to you know grow organoid
and then the once the corn is
established
you can nicely expand them over and over
for
weeks of culture so i don't think it is
a
you know some issue that you need to
think about
deeply so i would go for any of the two
thank you okay we have time for just a
few
more questions so the next question is
how
how big of a library can be used for
screening
and organoids and how did you check
for the representation of this library
oh it's a very good question so um
there are some paper papers saying that
they have achieved a genome-wide
library coverage but i think then
uh you are not introducing just one
guide to
one cell so what we found is that
uh with a 10 dish of
with a 10 centimeter 10 of 10 centimeter
dish
of organoids one can cover up to
4000 trnas
so that's the size that we will go from
now on
and i think it will be standardized in
such a way
so yeah so that's the complexity and um
could you repeat the question because i
forgot something to answer
sure let me pull it back up it says
um the second part of the question was
how did you check for the representation
of the library
oh yeah that's very important too so
after
performing the infection uh we then
compare within then harvest uh 10 of the
infected organoids
and isolate your genomic dna to do
ptr over the grna and then we
also sent it out for next generation
sequencing
to see what's the coverage so
up to four thousand uh we saw that the
coverage rate was
more than 95 percent so that was pretty
good
uh so we believe that the construct
current method that we developed is
probably
well optimized for for the 4000
grna diversity
great thank you okay so it says for
crispr
applications and mouse organoids
is there any recommendation on whether
to use plasmid
encoded cath9 rna guide or the
rnp directly
um i think this is
actually just a choice of you
some people like likes to use rmps
more than case 9 plasmid
just for my left we are still using
uh george turkey's very first cas9
plasmid which has been working very well
in our hands
so we haven't really changed our
tools to other more fancy ones
but i believe that i saw some very nice
applications with a ks9 rmp in ips cells
so probably applying those to organelles
may enhance the editing efficiency
thank you now how do you enrich growing
deficient
single colonies due to ko from others
during the screen
uh could you repeat the question sure
how do you enrich growing deficient
single
colonies due to ko from
others during the screens
yeah this i i i couldn't understand
okay let's go ahead and move on to
another question and we
can come back to this one yeah so let's
go ahead and let's see
we have so many great questions okay
does
cystic fibrosis always lead to cancer
um no so
cystic fibrosis actually leads to
inflammation so chronic inflammation is
the major problem uh
and then uh patients uh you know
uh yeah usually die around the age of
uh 40 or before so
um yeah i i don't know whether my answer
is
uh good enough for the question but
that's what i know
that's great thank you okay
looks like we have time for just a few
more questions
and this question says can the organoid
be able to study
severe genetic disorders like turner
syndrome
um so it depends on
what kind of syndrome it is
so some of the genetic disease that
shows
a very
pleasatropic phenotype it might be
not so easy to model both with the
organoids
however if you know clearly a
a organ that shows the diseased
phenotype
i believe that organelle could be a very
nice modal system to
uh to utilize so i don't think organized
will solve
everything but it will be very useful
uh if you you know know how where to use
it
great thank you okay we're going to go
ahead and wrap up with this last
question and your last question is
is there any difference in the gene
editing efficiency
when you use different parts of the
small intestine
oh that's interesting well but i
i personally have not uh compared the
gene editing efficiency
in those three uh different segments of
the small intestine so
uh well this is a question i cannot
really answer
sorry about that
well thank you bk for your time today
and do you have any final comments
for our audience before we go
oh well i think all the questions that i
got today was
very uh interesting and exciting to
answer
so i think that i have
given my presentation well enough
i hope everybody have has enjoyed it
and thank you again for attending this
seminar
thank you very much
thank you and before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their questions
any questions we did not have time for
today will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to thank ubk for your time today
and for your
important research we would also like to
thank lavers
and our sponsor jenscript for
underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand and labyrinths
will alert you when it's available for
replay
until next time goodbye